we should all be very scared right now
of Greg
people have made what they call time
cloaks what they did is you picture this
picture that I made where I said okay
there's this hidden region there's a
cloak around it and the light goes
around it like that and so imagine this
is like the horizontal position this is
the vertical position replace one of
those axes with time
and now at least in a picture you've
made a Time cloak you can design a
structure where it kind of hides events
in a certain time regime from light
okay now you sound dangerous
we should all be very scared right now
of Greg
he's a very dangerous man people
occasionally say that about me and then
I say but I am kind of lazy so it all
kind of balances out